The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to
lecture number 9.
In this lecture, I would like
to discuss with you the
solution of equilibrium
equations in static analysis.
In the earlier lectures, we
derived equations KU equals R.
And we now have to solve
these equations for the
displacements stored
in the vector U.
This is an important phase of
the finite element analysis,
because much of the
computational effort goes into
the solution of these
equations.
In the earliest finite element
analyses, iterative methods
were used, among them the
Gauss-Seidel method.
Now, the basic disadvantage of
using an iterative method is
that we do not know how many
iterations have to be
performed for solution, and thus
it is very difficult to
estimate the total solution
effort to solve the equations
KU equals R. Now we use almost
exclusively direct methods, or
computer programs that are in
industry, in abundance use,
are basically using
direct methods.
And these direct methods are
basically variations of Gauss
elimination, a method that
Gauss some 100 years ago
proposed for the solution
of equations.
Now we are talking about
static condensation,
substructuring, frontal
solution, LDL transpose
factorization, Cholesky
decomposition.
We are also talking about the
crude method, the column
reduction skyline solver.
But all of these methods are
indeed variations of the basic
Gauss elimination procedure.
These are direct methods
because the number of
operations can be counted for
the solution of the equations.
In fact, the number of
operations for a system with n
equations, a half bandwidth m,
is 1/2 nm squared, where we of
course use a half bandwidth
m that is
constant for the system.
If the bandwidth varied, some
adjustments have to be made to
that variable m.
A mean value has to be used.
However, the important point is
that we actually can count
the number of operations to
obtain the solution, which was
not the case in the iterative
method, because we did not
know how many iterations
have to be performed.
What I would like to do now
in this lecture is to very
briefly review with you how the
basic Gauss elimination is
performed, and then I would like
to show to you how this
method is indeed the basis
of static condensation
substructuring, et cetera.
We will finally also consider
the column reduction skyline
solver, which is very
effectively used, and that is
in fact the equation solver that
is used in Sab and the
ADINA program.
Well, I have prepared, as
before, some view graphs here.
And the first view graph here
shows a system of equations.
This is the K matrix here.
This is a displacement vector.
This a load vector.
And I will show you later on a
physical system which in fact
gives this stiffness matrix K.
But let's look now at the
system simply as an example
for solving equations.
In the basic Gauss elimination
procedure,
we proceed as follows.
We subtract a multiple of this
equation here from the second
equation and the third equation
in order to produce
here a 0, and to produce
here a 0.
Well, to obtain a 0 here, we
have to take 1/5 of this
equation, 1/5 of that equation,
and subtract it from
this equation.
1/5 because then we obtain a 1
here, and that 1 knocks that 1
out to obtain a 0.
We have to subtract minus 4/5
of this equation from the
second equation, and we
obtain a 0 here, too.
While this process is shown on
the next view graph, the
result of that process is
this set of equations.
We now have produced our
0 here, our 0 here.
Of course we had already
a 0 here.
We will see later on that the
matrix in here, the 3-by-3
matrix, bounded by the dash
lines on the side, in fact
represents a stiffness matrix.
That's important, because a
stiffness matrix has always
positive elements
on the diagonal.
Otherwise it is not a
stiffness matrix.
It does not govern a
stable structure.
See, here we have diagonal
elements that are all
positive, and if we can show
that in the Gauss elimination
procedure, we are still always
producing new stiffness
matrices, here a 3-by-3 matrix,
then we directly can
conclude that the diagonal
elements must remain positive.
Well, in the Gauss elimination
procedure, the same process
that we use to obtain from the
4-by-4 or 3-by-3 system is now
carried on to obtain, from
the 3-by-3 system,
a new 2-by-2 system.
This means that we have to
subtract a multiple of the
third equation from the fourth
equation and the fifth
equation in order to obtain
a 0 here and a 0 here.
For example, 5/14 of the second
equation is subtracted
from the fourth equation
to obtain a 0 here.
The result of that operation
is this matrix here.
Now we have a 2-by-2
matrix here.
Again, positive elements
on the diagonal.
In fact, this is a 2-by-2
stiffness matrix, as I will be
showing to you just now.
Finally we proceed again, once
more, with the same step, to
produce a 0 here, which means
that we have to subtract from
this fourth equation a
minus 20/7 divided by
15/7 of this equation.
And the result, then, is this
set of equations here.
Notice that we now have a single
element here, and in
fact, this is a stiffness
matrix, in this case, a 1-by-1
stiffness matrix, just one
element, that governs the
behavior of a single spring.
The solution off the equations
is now completed by solving
for u4 from this relation
down here.
This is a 1 degree of
freedom system.
Knowing u4, we can go back to
this equation here, substitute
u4 in, and the only unknown
variable is u3.
We solve, therefore, u3
from this equation.
Now we know u4 and u3.
We now go to this equation.
Knowing u3 u4, the only
unknown in this
equation here is now u2.
We can calculate u2, and
repeating the process, we can
calculate u1.
A very simple, straightforward
procedure,
but extremely powerful.
The result of that solution
is shown here.
Notice u1 is simply obtained
by this operation here.
Of course, here we're having
u2 and u3 in that we
calculated already.
u2 is calculated here. u4
is calculated here.
It might be easier to actually
look at it the way we
discussed it just now.
We call that the back
substitution, because we are
coming from below upwards, and
in the back substitution, we
have u4 first.
We then calculate u3.
u4 is known now, remember.
We can substitute directly u4
into here, and we get u3.
Knowing now u3 and u4, we can
get u2, as shown here.
And finally, we get u2.
This is the basic Gauss
elimination procedure, an
extremely powerful process.
And I would like to show you
know how this procedure
relates to the static
condensation and relates to
the other techniques, and how
we then actually use this
basic Gauss elimination
procedure in an actual finite
element program.
Well, static condensation is the
first topic that I'd like
to talk about.
The basic process is here that
we are partitioning the total
matrix into the following
parts.
A Kaa, Kac, Kca, and Kcc part.
The cc part goes with Uc, the
displacements Uc, which we
want to condense
statically out.
Notice I'm putting the degrees
of freedom that I want to
condense out at the bottom
of the U vector.
Well, by static condensation we
mean that we express Uc in
terms of Ua, which this equation
here is obtained from
the bottom equation here.
We then substitute Uc in the
top equation here, and the
result is this equation here.
Notice that the results can
be remembered quite easily
because we have here an aa, Kaa,
then we have an a here, a
c, a cc, ca.
Notice that one might say, just
for remembering it, that
this c knocks out that c, this
c knocks out that c, and what
we are left with are aa's.
And that means an aa
here, an aa here.
So the dimensions are compatible
of the matrices,
and the result is, I call
it here, K bar aa.
Of course the right-hand side
has also changed, because the
components must have an effect
on the equation that give Ua.
Well, let's look at this
process, called the static
condensation process, for
our simple example.
And in this example now,
I deliberately
put the Kcc up here.
In other words, the Uc degree
of freedom is now the U1.
This is all our Uc vector only
containing now one component.
The static condensation was
originally proposed by
considering or statically
condensing out of the last
equation, and that is how it's
usually used also in finite
element analysis.
As an example, if we have
incompatible modes, we might
condense out the incompatible
degrees of freedom, just as
shown here.
Or if we have internal degrees
of freedom in finite elements
that only that only couple with
the bound the degrees of
freedom of a finite element,
we could condense them out
this way, and then we would have
this as the last degree
of freedom.
This would be Uc degrees of
freedom, and we would condense
them out, just as shown here.
However, in order to show you
how the static condensation
relates to Gauss elimination, I
want to look at the example
that we looked at earlier
already, and this the
partitioning I have used.
U1 now being the UC,
U2 U4 being the
Ua degrees of freedom.
So I want to now statically
condense out Uc.
The result of the K bar
aa is shown here.
Notice we are taking this part,
this part here, this
part here goes right there,
this vector here is this
vector here, 1/5 is the inverse
of Kcc, and this
vector here is that
vector there.
Well, performing these
operations, the
result is this one here.
That is the result.
And if we go back to our earlier
Gauss elimination
procedure, we in fact notice
that this matrix, K bar aa, is
nothing else than the matrix
that we derived from the
4-by-4 system when we eliminated
the non-zero
elements here.
In other words, we subtracted in
the Gauss elimination from
the second equation and the
third equation a multiple of
the first equation, we
got these zeros here.
The result was this
3-by-3 matrix.
And that 3-by-3 matrix is
exactly this matrix.
So what have we been doing then
in the Gauss elimination?
We have really statically
condensed out the first degree
of freedom, and we have obtained
a stiffness matrix, K
bar aa, in that Gauss
elimination procedure.
We can now also look at the
physics that we have been
going through, and this is,
in my opinion, a very
important part also.
We start off with this
matrix here.
Notice the following00 this now
is the stiffness matrix of
this beam for the U1 to the
U4 degrees of freedom.
This stiffness matrix actually
has been derived by finite
differences.
It is a nice example to show
demonstratively what happens
in the Gauss elimination.
Of course, we could've also used
a finite element system,
but I chose here a finite
difference matrix, which is
still a stiffness matrix, and
which I can use very nicely to
show to you the basic procedures
of the Gauss
elimination.
So this stiffness matrix
governed this system here.
Notice the following.
The first column, this column
here, represents the forces.
When I displace this node, if
you think of this as a note,
by unity, and keep all
the other degrees
of freedom to 0--
in other words, if I
put this deflected
shape onto the beam--
0 displacements right here, but
a unit displacement here.
That is a unit displacement.
Now notice, these are the forces
that have to act at
these degrees of freedom
in order to give
this deflected shape.
The force here, if I
put them here in
blue, is 5, as an example.
The force here is minus 4.
The force here is 1, and the
force here turns out to be 0.
That element, or that element,
of course, we
have a symmetric matrix.
And of course, in the same way,
we can interpret other
elements in this matrix.
1 column represents always
forces that have to act onto
the system in order to obtain
unit displacements at 1 degree
of freedom.
If you look at the I's
column, then it's the
I's degree of freedom.
And all the other degrees
of freedom are set to 0.
Well, if we perform our Gauss
elimination or static
condensation-- we have shown
that it is the same--
on this system, in the
first step, we
obtain a 3-by-3 matrix.
Physically, what we have
obtained is the stiffness
matrix of this system now.
And the following important
point is now to be noted.
If I look at this column just in
the same way as I looked at
the first column of the 4-by-4
system, then this column
represents now the forces that
are required at these degrees
of freedom to impose a unit
displacement here at this
degree of freedom, this now
being unity, with 0
displacements here.
And the force required
here is 14/5.
That is the force that I have
to apply here to get a unit
displacement here.
At the same time, I have to
apply here a force of minus
16/5, and I have to apply
here a force of 1.
So I'm talking again about
forces acting onto the system
in this matrix here.
And these forces are stored in
the columns or the rows off
the matrix, and in the I's
column or row, I have the
forces required to impose a unit
displacement at the I's
degree of freedom with all the
degrees of freedom being 0.
And the important point is that
having performed now the
Gauss elimination, here
I do not have
anymore a degree of freedom.
The system is free
to go down here.
And that's what we mean by
static condensation, really.
We have taken a degree of
freedom out of the system.
Proceeding in the same way, we
obtain this 2 by 2 system.
Now we only have 2 degrees
of freedom.
I have condensed out this degree
of freedom and that
degree of freedom,
which were there.
The beam is now free to move
down here, so the deflected
shape corresponding to U3, this
one here, would be like
that, with 0 displacement
here, and unit
displacement there.
The forces required at these
degrees of freedom are stored
in this column here.
Now, we immediately can observe
that since we are
talking about a physical system
into which we have to
put energy to deform it, we
can conclude that these
elements here must be
positive elements.
In other words, the diagonal
elements in the stiffness
matrices that we derive
must be positive.
They must be positive because
if I push down the U3 degree
of freedom to obtain a unit
displacement, surely the force
that I have to apply here
must be positive.
In other words, it must be a
force into the direction of
the degree of freedom U3.
And that means this must
be a positive element.
So if, in a Gauss elimination
procedure, we obtain, all of a
sudden, a negative diagonal
element, this one or that one,
as an example, then we would
know that the structure we are
analyzing is unstable.
In the final step of the Gauss
elimination, we obtain a
single degree of
freedom system.
And that single degree
of freedom system
behaves like that.
Notice no more degree
of freedoms here.
And the equation--
I have to apologize that this
matrix has been written a
little bit down.
It should be a little
bit higher.
They should, of course, be
aligned these three.
But basically, we have 5/6
times U4 equals 7/6.
And this here is really
nothing else than the
stiffness of a spring.
A spring K having
us a number 5/6.
In other words, a spring
stiffness of 5/6 here.
This is U4, the U4 degree
of freedom.
And the force applied to
that spring is 7/6.
We have a single degree
of freedom system.
But notice that this single
degree of freedom system, this
stiffness now, K equals 5/6,
contains really all the
physical properties
of that beam.
The effect of the other degrees
of freedom, U1, U2,
U3, have been carried over into
this spring stiffness.
Similarly, 7/6 is the force
which is a result off the
other forces that were
applied to the
other degrees of freedom.
And now from the single degree
of freedom system, of course,
we can solve for U4, and then we
go back to the 2 degree of
freedom system to solve
for U3, and so on.
By that back substitution
process, we obtain thus the
displacement that the beam
is actually undergoing.
So the important point is that
when we do perform Gauss
elimination, we really operate
always on physical systems.
We operate always from one
stiffness matrix on to another
stiffness matrix, and the next
stiffness matrix is basically
obtained by static
condensation.
We are statically condensing
out 1 degree of
freedom after the next.
Well, if that is very well
understood, and I urge you to
read up in the book on this
procedure, then I think you
can very well appreciate how
the substructuring process,
frontal solution method,
directly relates, again, to
Gauss elimination.
And here I summarize once the
basic procedure that we use in
substructuring analysis.
We really go through static
condensation on the internal
degrees of freedom of
a substructure.
Here I'm showing a substructure,
which is an
assemblage, in this case, of
the plane stress 4-node
elements, just for
illustration.
Of course, there could be beam
elements internally here or
externally here.
There could be shell elements.
Any kind of elements.
But the important point is that
we have an assemblage of
elements, which by itself,
of course, gives
us a structure already.
We use static condensation on
the internal degrees of
freedom of the substructure.
Well, the result, then, is a
new stiffness matrix of the
substructure involving boundary
degrees of freedom only.
Let us look, then,
at this example.
Here we have 2 degrees of
freedom at each node.
At the boundary nodes, which are
shown solid, here, and the
hollow points here, the
circles here are
the internal nodes.
2 degrees of freedom at each.
The result is that we have a
50-by-50 stiffness matrix,
because we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
nodes along this length, and 5
layers this way.
So 25 nodes times 2 degrees of
freedom per node gives us a
50-by-50 stiffness matrix.
Now what we do in the
substructuring analysis, we
statically condense out the
internal degrees of freedom,
just in the way I have shown
how we condense out in that
beam element, in that beam
analysis, U1 to U3, the same
way we are condensing out the
internal degrees of freedom.
Notice that we do not need to
perform Gauss elimination from
U1 to U3 or U4 onwards.
We could also first deal with
U2, then with U4, then with
U1, and then solve for U3.
So we have really a lot of
flexibility in the Gauss
elimination procedure.
The important point is that now
we're using it to condense
these internal degrees
of freedom out.
The result, then, is a stiffness
matrix that only
involves the boundary
degrees of freedom.
Now in this case, we have 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 nodes here.
Another 5 is 10.
3 here and 3 here means 16,
times 2 means it's going to be
is 32 by 32 stiffness matrix.
Notice that the internal degrees
of freedom have been
statically condensed out, which
means that if I impose,
for example, a unit displacement
here, keeping all
the other displacements 0 at
the other nodes, and I keep
this one also 0, then in this
case, I would have internal
displacements at these nodes.
Whereas in this case, if I put
a unit displacement only
corresponding to this degree of
freedom and keep all other
displacements equal to 0, I
would have 0 displacements at
these nodes, at these points.
Here these nodes are free to go
wherever they want to go in
the finite element solution.
And if I put a unit displacement
on here, they
will be taking on a
particular value.
These nodal displacements will
take on a particular value.
What we really have derived,
and this is important, is a
new stiffness matrix.
A new, we might call it, element
stiffness matrix.
A superelement, or substructure
These are all equivalent words
that, however, only involve
boundary degrees of freedom.
This is now a new finite element
that can be used just
as any ordinary finite element
in the assemblage process to
obtain the stiffness matrix
of the complete structure.
Let me show to you
a simple example.
Here is a very simple structure,
a truss element
that has only 3 degrees
of freedom.
U1, U2, U3.
The stiffness matrix of
that truss element is
shown here as 3-by-3.
Matrix here, we see U1,
U2, U3, and the forces
corresponding to these degrees
of freedom, of course, are
listed here.
The objective in this example is
to statically condense out
this degree of freedom, and
thus obtain a new element
stiffness matrix that only
involve the boundary degrees
of freedom.
Well, the first step that I've
pursued here was to rearrange
the equation so as to have U1
and U3 as the top equations,
and U2 as the bottom equation.
So we want to do static
condensation now from the
back, or from the bottom, the
way it's usually done.
And it's usually done that way
because it is numerically
effective to proceed that way.
The result, then,
is shown here.
We write down just
to identify, to
use the various parts.
This matrix here is this
2-by-2 matrix.
This minus 20, minus 28
is that one here.
Here we get the Kcc inverse,
which is this part here, and
then of course here we have
this vector, shown here.
If we perform these
multiplications here, we
obtain this stiffness
matrix here.
A 1 minus 1 minus 11 with
a constant in front.
Of course, the load vector
also has changed.
There is a carry over from the
2 degree of freedom in to the
1 and 3 degrees of freedom.
The U2 degree of freedom then
can be recovered via this
equation here, going back to
the original equation.
The important point is that
we have now obtained the
stiffness matrix of the truss
element, this stiffness matrix
of the trust element, involving
U1 and U3 only.
U2 is not anymore present.
It has been statically
condensed out.
The U2 will adjust itself to a
particular value, and that
value, of course, is
given right here.
But the stiffness matrix that
we have now here only
corresponds to U1 and U3.
Well, that process can then
be repeated, and we can go
through a process that we call
multilevel substructuring.
In other words, we don't
just go once through a
substructuring process, but
we go repeatedly through
substructuring processes.
And basically, what we are doing
is we are solving the
system of equations KU equals R
of the complete system in a
very effective way.
Let me show you here
an example.
Here we have a simple
truss assemblage.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4 elements.
The important point
is here that the
elements are all similar.
The area is varying 2A1,
4A1, 8A1, 16A1.
And what I want to do is,
I want to deal now, via
substructuring with the
equations to obtain a very
effective solution.
The first step is to look at
this element, which involves
U1 and U3 and U2.
And here you see, once more,
a sketch of that element.
That is the element here.
Now I condense out U2, and
that's what we just did in the
previous example.
The only degrees of freedom
that we are left with,
then, are U1 U3.
So now we have an element
stiffness matrix, this element
stiffness matrix, but in terms
of U1 and U3 only.
The next step, then,
is to say, let
us repeat this process.
Let us now say, since we have
this element stiffness matrix
here in terms of U1 and U3 only,
and since this adamant
is similar to this element here,
there is only a scalar
involved because the area is
varying as shown, from A1 to
2A1 to 4A1 and so on, we can
use this stiffness matrix
here, this element stiffness
matrix, which, however, is
already a substructure the way
I've defined it, to assemble
the stiffness matrix
corresponding to
both of these elements.
And that process is
schematically shown here.
This stiffness matrix now will
involve U1, U3, and U5.
Notice U2 is gone, and the
important point U4 is gone
also, because I've dealt with
U2, I have statically
condensed out U2, and by that,
of course, I also have
statically condensed out U4
simultaneously, because I'm
using this element stiffness
matrix here again.
So U4 is also gone already.
And now all I need to do is
condense out U3, and I obtain
a second level substructure,
which I can use again now to
assemble this element here
with that element.
And that is shown on the
next view graph here.
I repeat that process using this
element here now, which
is this part here, involving
only U1 and U5, and this
element here, which is similar
to that element.
Again, an area variation
there, of course.
And I obtain an element
stiffness matrix, or a
structural stiffness matrix,
whichever way you want to look
at it, that involves U1,
U5, and U9 only.
I can now statically
condense out U5.
The only unknowns I'm left with
are U1 and U9, and of
course then I can simply
solve for U1 and U9.
Of course, we would have
to have also one of the
displacement being
prescribed to
actually perform a solution.
Otherwise we have a rigid
body mode in the system.
Assuming that, say, U1 is 0, we
now would impose U1 being
0, solve for U9, go back, solve
for U5, and proceed
backwards to solve for all
the displacements.
The important point is that
via this substructuring
process, a multilevel
substructuring process, we
have saved operations.
We have saved operations because
in this particular
case, you see, I have condensed
out these degrees of
freedom already, and I use this
fact in this assemblage
process and solution in such a
way as that I do not need to
condense out these degrees of
freedom, that I do not need to
deal with these degrees of
freedom again, because I've
dealt with them in effect
already by condensing out
these degrees of freedom here.
There are also other
advantages using
substructuring, and one
important advantage that I
should mention is that in the
input definition phase, we
only need to define the
elements, nodal points, and so
on of a typical substructure,
and we can use that definition
in a computer program, then,
again and again, to assemble
the complete structure.
In other words, if I have
defined, typically for a
high-rise building, one typical
floor, and I have
assembled the floor stiffness
matrix with columns, beams,
and so on, that pertain to
that floor, if I then
statically condense out the
degrees of freedom that we
want to condense out for that
part of the substructure, I
can use that floor substructure,
so to say, again
and again, to assemble the
complete building structure.
And this means I only have to
define really the particular
substructure input, and I
deal, then, with that
substructure numerically,
as I have
shown here in the example.
The next important procedure
that I like to discuss very
briefly with you is the
frontal solution.
And the frontal solution really,
again, only represents
a variation of the basic Gauss
elimination procedure.
It represents, really, a static
condensation procedure.
And that static condensation,
however, is performed in a
particular way.
And this is really where the
advantages of the frontal
solution can lie.
It's performed via looking
at the elements.
Let me describe to you
the basic process.
Here we have, as an example, a
two-dimensional plane stress
element mesh.
We have 4-node elements, as
shown here, element 1, element
2, element 3, element 4,
q, q plus 1, and so on.
In other words, there's a whole
lay of elements this
way, and that way, and so on.
This mesh could represent, for
example, a cantilever plate
that acts in plane stress.
In the frontal solution, the
solution of the KU equals R
equation is performed
by elements.
So we're putting in element 1,
which couples into node 1,
node 2, node m, and
node n plus 1.
Since the degrees of freedom
at node 1 only obtain
stiffness from element 1, and
no other element, the
assemblage of this element
into the global structure
stiffness matrix gives
the only stiffness
contribution at node 1.
Therefore, we have the final
equations at node 1, and we
can deal with them already.
And that's how the frontal
solution proceeds now.
It statically condenses out
these degrees of freedom.
Then we move on to the
next node of element
1, this node here.
However, this node gets
stiffness from element
1 and element 2.
So in order to obtain the final
equations here, we have
to add the element 2 stiffness
matrix to the element 1
stiffness matrix.
And that means in this way,
then, of course, we obtain the
final equation, corresponding
to node 2.
We now can statically condense
out the degrees of
freedom at node 2.
We then move on to the next
node, involving element 1 and
element 2, which
is node 3, say.
And now we have to, however,
assemble the stiffness matrix
of elements 3, also into the
equations that we have
assembled already.
Having done so, we can now use
static condensation to
condense out these degrees
of freedom.
We proceed, therefore, via
elements, and we are talking
about a wave front--
which is this one for node 1,
this is the wave front for
node 2, this is the
wave front--
in other words, what we are
saying is, the wave front
really embodies or contains all
the elements that we need
to have assembled before
we can condense
out degrees of freedom.
To condense out the degrees of
freedom at node 2, we have to
have a wave front such
as shown here.
We have to have assembled
element 1 and 2, because
element 1 and element 2 give
stiffness to node 2.
The important point is that we
are proceeding via static
condensation from node 1 to
node 2 and so on, and this
means really that we
are performing
Gauss elimination again.
The process is summarized
here once more.
The frontal solution consists
of successive static
condensation of nodal
degrees for freedom.
The solution is performed
in the order
of the element numbering.
That's important.
Same number of operations are
performed in the frontal
solution as in the skyline
solution, if the element
numbering in the wave front
solution corresponds to the
nodal point numbering in
the skyline solution.
So if the element numbering
in the frontal solution
corresponds to the nodal point
numbering in the skyline
solution, we perform in the
skyline solution, which I have
not really talked about yet, and
that's what I want to get
on now, the same number
of operations as
in the frontal solution.
By corresponding, I mean in this
particular case here, we
would condense out in the
frontal solution the degrees
of freedom at node 1, then 2,
then 3, then 4, and so on.
And of course, in the skyline
solution, or in the Gauss
elimination procedure, we also
proceed via node 1, 2,
3, 4, and so on.
So in this particular example,
the frontal solution and the
skyline solution would give the
same number of operations.
Well, let me go on to the
skyline solution, then.
And the basis of that solution
is LDL transpose
factorization.
Basically again, Gauss
elimination.
The basic step here
is the following.
We are having our stiffness
matrix, K here, and now I'm
going back to that example which
I discussed earlier, the
beam example.
We're talking about the 4-by-4
stiffness matrix again.
We're using this stiffness
matrix, and we premultiply it
by an L1 inverse matrix,
this matrix here.
In fact we never perform
formally this
premultiplication via matrix,
because what this does is, it
subtracts a multiple of this
first row from the rows below
it to update a 0 here
and a 0 there.
That's all this
premultiplication does.
And the result is this matrix
here, which I've shown to you
earlier already.
The next step is then
to operate on this
matrix in the same way.
However, before doing so, let me
show you here a view graph
in which I have written out
specifically the L1 inverse.
And the important point, L1.
Notice that L1, the inverse of
this matrix, is obtained by
trivial operation.
Namely, simply changing the plus
here to a minus sign, and
the minus sign to a plus here.
Changing the signs of the
off-diagonal elements gives us
directly the inverse
of that matrix.
Well, having obtained,
therefore, via this operation,
or having carried out via this
operation, I should say, the
first step of the basic Gauss
elimination procedure, namely
subtracting the top row from
the rows below it to obtain
zeroes in the first column below
the diagonal element, we
proceed in the same way.
and via this procedure here--
now, of course, we have an L2
inverse, and so on-- we obtain
what we call an upper
triangular matrix.
S, an upper triangular matrix.
Zeroes all below the diagonal,
and only non-zero elements
right here.
Of course, if the matrix has a
bandwidth originally, that
bandwidth would be preserved,
and we would have no non-zero
elements outside that band.
In other words, all elements
outside the band would, in
fact, be also zero elements.
This upper triangular matrix,
then, obtained--
this is the S matrix, here--
will be used in the
back substitution.
This is here the element that
gives us the single degree of
freedom stiffness, which I
talked about earlier, from
which we can solve Un.
Here I'm talking about
a general case with
n degrees of freedom.
However, looking at this
equation, let us first
identify that we can put all of
these inverse matrices onto
the right-hand side, and we
obtain this equation here.
Now notice that this L1 is
obtained by trivial operation
from L1 inverse.
The same holds for
L2 and so on.
So we never really had
to invert a matrix to
obtain this part here.
Furthermore, this L1 was an
identity matrix with only
non-zero, off-diagonal elements
in the first column.
This one is a matrix which
looks like the identity
matrix, but has also non-zero,
off-diagonal elements in the
second column.
And so on.
And the product of these
matrices here, then, is very
simply obtained by writing
the 1's into the diagonal
positions, and the off-diagonal
elements here are
those of L1 in the first column,
those of L2 in the
second column, and so on.
So even this multiplication is
obtained in a very simple way.
We only need to write the first
column of L1 into here,
the second column of L2
into here, the third
column of L3 into here.
And the result, all of that,
I call the L matrix.
Now notice that once again, we
do not perform any matrix
multiplication.
We have n minus 1 matrices here,
but we do not perform a
matrix multiplication, because
all we do is, we take the
first column of L1 and put it
into the first column of L.
The second column of L2 is the
second column in L. The n
minus second column in L is
nothing else than the n minus
second column in L n minus 2.
And so on.
The result, therefore, is that
we have written k equal to Lf,
L being equal to this
product here.
Now because K is symmetric, we
can, in fact, write this F
matrix here as D times L
transposed, where d is a
diagonal matrix, dii
being equal to sii.
So now we have factorized the K
matrix into LDL transposed.
The d elements, or the dii
elements, must all be positive
if our structure is stable,
as I pointed out earlier.
The Cholesky factorization,
just by remark, uses this
form, K being L curl times L
curl transpose, where we
should note that L curl is
really nothing else than L
times d to the 1/2, where d to
the 1/2 is obtained by using
the D matrix and taking
square roots of
the diagonal elements.
In other words, the ith
elemental of d to the 1/2 is
nothing else than square
root out of dii.
Well, having performed the LDL
transpose factorization, we
now are ready to solve the
equations, and they are solved
in the following steps.
We have LV equals R, where V
is defined as shown here.
Notice that if I were to put
this part into there, I really
obtain nothing else than LDL
transpose times U equals R,
where this is, of course,
nothing else than K times U
equals R, if I were
to substitute
from here into there.
However, we separate these two
steps out, and we call this
the forward reduction of R,
which is really obtained by
subtracting specific elements
of R from other elements.
We never really perform
a matrix product here.
We write it that way, but
really, it means nothing else
than taking, say, the ith
element off R and subtracting
that element, or multiple of
that element, from the
elements below it.
That is a typical operation
performed when
we form the V vector.
Having obtained V, we go back to
this equation here, and we
perform this step.
Notice that this step is nothing
else than the division
off the V elements by
the D elements.
In other words, here we take
Vi and divide it by dii.
The final step, then, is the
back substitution, which gives
us U. The back substitution
is performed
as I discussed earlier.
Already we're going from UN,
from the last degree of
freedom, upwards to calculate
the values of
the degrees of freedom.
Let us now look at the actual
implementation.
The implementation has
to be performed very
effectively, of course.
All I have been giving to
you now so far were the
mathematical equations that we
are basically operating on.
The LDL transpose factorization
is, of course, a
way of writing a set of steps
of solution that we are
performing.
However, we want to perform
them as effectively as
possible, and the scheme that
we're using is related,
really, to the crude scheme--
we call it the column
reduction scheme--
that we are going through for
the solution of the equation.
And the procedure that we're
using is as follows.
Here we have the stiffness
matrix.
Notice that we only store
the upper part.
Since we have a asymmetric
matrix, we can directly obtain
the lower part elements from
the upper part elements.
We do not need to store them
in the computer program.
We also perform the Gauss
elimination in a very, you
might say, strange way, when
you look at it first.
And the way we're performing
it is the following.
That we are reducing
this column first.
In other words, we are
going column-wise.
We are reducing this
column first.
The result is that one.
In the next step, then, we are
going through the reduction of
the next column.
See here, we are now reducing
this column, and the
result is that one.
The dashed line always is on
the right-hand side of that
part of the matrix, which has
already been reduced.
And now we are looking here at
the third column, and this is
the reduction off the third
column The final step is then
that we are reducing
the fourth column,
and this is the result.
Now notice that having performed
these operations
column-wise--
and I have not given
you the details.
We do not have time
in this lecture
to look at the details.
The details are in the book, if
you want to read them up.
All I'd like to convey to you
now are the procedures that
we're using to show you
the effectiveness.
Notice that the final result
here in this operation is the
D matrix on the diagonal and
the L transpose in the
off-diagonal elements.
And we have done
it column-wise.
Well, what does this mean,
then, in practice?
In practice it means
the following.
Notice that I have now a system
which has different
column heights for different
equations.
The column heights are being
defined by the first non-zero
element in a column.
So this is the column height
for this last column here,
because this is the
first non-zero
element in the column.
The zero elements below this
element here, in general,
become non-zero elements.
In general, not always.
But because they in general
become non-zero elements, we
have defined our column
height this way.
And what we are now doing in the
actual solution is that we
are reducing, column by column,
just the way I have
shown it, to obtain finally the
elements of the D matrix
on the diagonal, and the
elements of the L transpose
matrix in the off-diagonal
elements here.
And we can do so--
this is important--
by simply replacing elements.
If you go back to an earlier
step that we looked at, what
we have done here is looked at
this matrix here, and we, in
the reduction process, simply
replaced this element by 1/5,
replaced this element by the
minus 4 element, by minus 8/7,
over and so on.
So we don't need additional
storage.
We can simply replace
elements.
In the same way, we proceed
now here, as shown, on the
next view graph.
Here we have filled in the
zero element, and the
reduction has been performed
column after column.
The effectiveness of this whole
procedure is really seen
on this view graph here, when
we talk about large systems.
I want to denote here this as
a large system, because the
high speed core storage is not
sufficient to store the
whole matrix in.
And so what we have been doing
is, we are storing
the matrix in blocks.
This is here the first block,
shown by the dashed line.
This is the second block.
This is the third block, and
that's the fourth block.
What I'm saying is that we
have divided the total
stiffness matrix into blocks,
and in fact, we divided the
blocks in such a way as to be
able to take always at least
two blocks into core.
In other words, in this solution
process, we have to
be able to take this
block into core,
that block into core.
Two blocks.
We also would have to be able to
take this block into core,
that block into core,
and so on.
Of course, the way this is
actually automatized in a
computer program, is that
we say we have so
much storage available.
Say that we have 40,000 storage
locations available.
Then for the solution of the
equations, or for the storing
of the stiffness matrix,
then 20,000 locations
would be used per block.
And what the solution routine
simply does-- it counts these
elements and puts this dashed
line in such a way that 20,000
elements are in here, 20,000
elements are in here,
and so on.
The solution procedure, or the
solution of the equation, is
now performed in the
following way,
using the block structure.
We proceed with the reduction
off this column, of that
column, of that column
and that column.
Now, I should point out the
following important point.
When we do we do reduce this
column, this column coupled
into the first equation.
So we have to have these
elements in core.
Of course, since this is 1
block, and since we can store
that block in core anyway,
there is no problem.
We can reduce this
column directly.
These elements that we
already have obtained
are indeed in core.
Now let's go on to
the second block.
The second block coupled into
the first block, because these
elements here couple into
these equations.
So in order to reduce the second
block column by column,
we have to have the first
block in core.
And that's what we do.
We take this block into core and
reduce the second block.
Having finished the second block
reduction, we go on to
the fourth block.
And the fourth block now is
reduced by first taking the
first block into core, because
the first block also couples
into the third block.
Then taking the second block
into core together with this
one, and reducing this one, and
then of course, finally,
we reduce this one.
So the general procedure,
therefore, is that we take a
particular block into core that
we want to reduce, we
have reduced already all the
previous blocks, we have
storage available also for one
of the previous blocks, and we
sequentially take the previous
blocks into core to take into
account all the coupling that
these previous blocks have
onto the current block that
we want to reduce.
In this example, we're taking
this block into core.
We then take first also
That means we have two
blocks in core.
We take the effect of
this block into
account onto that block.
Then we throw this book out.
We take this block into core.
We take the effect of this block
into account onto this
block, and finally, we reduce
the block by itself.
In the same way, we would
proceed with this block, just
as another example.
We take this block
into a core.
This one couples into all
previous blocks, so what we
have to do is take this into
core, and first take this into
core, take the effect of this
coupling into account onto
this block, throw this out, take
this one into core, put
this block coupling onto that
block, throw this out, take
this one into core, and finally
take the effect of
this block coupling onto that
one into account, and finally
then, of course, reduce
this block by itself.
This, then, completes
the complete
solution of a large system.
I only was able to give you
the basic principles, the
basic ideas.
Some of the details are
described in the textbook, and
you can read up there
further on it.
Thank you very much for
your attention.
This was all what I wanted
to say in this lecture.